bonsoir à toutes et à tous nous sommes
le mercredi 16 mars merci de nous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 le journal comme chaque jour nous
revenons sur votre actualité locale
entouré deux invités mais également des
journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite on commence avec les titres de
cette édition l'enfance créateur c'est
le thème de la nouvelle semaine de
l'enfance est en cours des ateliers des
moments d'âge des changes parents
professionnels sont proposés nous avons
suivi un atelier dédié à la motricité
siens vieillir chez soi elles sont
encore envisageables témoignages de
personnes âgées mais aussi des
auxiliaires de vie véronique chatel
journaliste yvelinoise amenez-le enquête
durant trois ans son ouvrage vient
d'être publié elle est l'invitée de ce
journal et puis retour sur les
simulations à grande échelle de la crue
centennale cette crue de la seine qui
pourraient survenir dans les prochaines
années et avoir de graves conséquences
dans l'ensemble du département et une
information pour commencer ce journal
hier soir à plaisir le corps d'une femme
de 54 ans a été découvert à son domicile
par son mari à son arrivée l'homme a
découvert son fils présents sur les
lieux selon des sources policières une
bagarre entre les deux hommes aurait
éclaté avant que le fils ne prenne la
fuite ce qui fait de lui le principal
suspect de cette affaire l'homme est
actuellement toujours recherché est la
sixième semaine de l'industrie se
poursuit aujourd'hui la chambre de
commerce et de l'industrie de versailles
a organisé une table ronde sur la
transformation des usines et des
entreprises
au programme de cette matinée une séance
de questions réponses avec les sociétés
yvelinoise dont les responsables de psa
poissy et de l'école d'ingénieurs estaca
l'événement attiré des demandeurs
d'emploi en phase de reconversion et
surtout des étudiants ils étaient une
quarantaine à avoir assisté à la
conférence on écoute j'accomplis n'est
élu à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie il était au micro des
métiers les libéraux je peux vous dire
que ça nous fait grandement plaisir
puisque hélas quand on parle de
l'automobile s'est souvent d'une manière
négative en termes de licenciements et
autres et la voir des jeunes qui se
destinent et qui sont intéressés par la
filière
riel et ses nouvelles technologies
notamment dans le cadre de l' usine du
futur je peux vous dire que oui nous
chambre de commerce ça nous fait
grandement plaisir et du 14 au 18 mars
et la semaine de la petite enfance la
ville d'elancourt organise pour
l'occasion des portes ouvertes et des
ateliers dans ces établissements autour
du thème de l'enfant créateur il hier
c'était la crèche le petit prince dans
le quartier de la vision qui accueillait
parents et enfants pour évoquer la
motricité mais à l'époque et pour ce
reportage
une simple boîte en carton et pourtant
lucas s'amuse avec sa maman un matériel
tout simple qui aide au développement de
la motricité des plus petits
pour le coup la tranche d'âge de la
crèche c'est toute l'évolution on voit
vraiment je vais dire à partir du moment
où me rentrent c'est que justement tout
ses auteurs de tapis je veux dire de
structure même je dire de mousse va être
intéressante parce que je voyais andreu
tout à l'heure qui montent et descendent
et du matelas
elle va répéter plusieurs fois pour
mesurer ses capacités et ses ses
sensations pour voir comment aider ne
pouvait se débrouiller que matérielles
qui avait la crèche et que pour nous
ensuite à la maison pouvez aussi essayer
de faire pareil et puis c'est bien aussi
d'être entouré d'une équipe de
professionnels
c'est notre premier et c'est vrai que ça
pourrait vraiment nous aider pour après
l'aider lui dans son évolution
pour sa première participation à la
semaine de la petite enfance la commune
bel encouragement choisi d'ouvrir des
portes de ces établissements aux parents
jusqu'à présent les crèches étaient
relativement ouverte de façon très très
facile aux parents mais on s'est dit que
c'était une belle façon effectivement de
compléter notre notre label ville amie
des enfants et de partager encore
davantage avec les familles
c'est une politique très importante nous
accueillons aujourd'hui sur cette
structure quelque chose comme quatre
cent cinquante enfants
nous avons de véritables professionnels
la commune organise aussi une conférence
sur le jeu chez l'enfant de 0 à 3 ans
animés par des psychologues et des
psychomotriciens et deuxième épisode
troisième épisode pardon notre série de
reportages consacrés à l'artisanat la
semaine de l'artisanat se poursuit
jusqu'au 18 mars je le rappelle
l'artisanat
première entreprise de france et cette
semaine est donc l'occasion de rendre
hommage à nos artisans il y as nous vous
avons fait découvrir la peinture sur
porcelaine
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
aux bijoux à maurepas frédéric va
longtemps s'est lancé depuis deux ans
dans la création de bijoux au filigrane
d'argent camille lambert est allé à sa
rencontre
elle nous raconte son histoire regarder
j'aime beaucoup les papillons j'ai fait
des pièces des pics à cheveux pour le
moment et je suis en train d'en décliner
en broche torsadé les courbes puis les
fixer un geste que frédéric répète de
nombreuses fois pour créer ses bijoux la
soudure est réalisé à l'aide d'un
chalumeau avoisinant les 1000 degrés sa
technique
le filigrane d'argent mon travail à
partir de fils d'argent différentes
sections de différentes tailles et en
fait on va créer une structure que l'on
va remplir d'ornements en fils d'argent
frédéric a fait une partie de sa
carrière dans l'ébénisterie avant de se
lancer dans la création de bijoux en
2013 alors qu'elle apprend le travail de
la pâte de métal elle a le coup de
foudre
j'ai découvert chez mon schéma prof
un bijou en filigrane en fait et j'ai
été si vous inquiète par la neige ou de
parfum par le bijou par là la finesse de
ce travail et ça m'a donné envie de
d'apprendre cette technique selon
l'enseignement les formations en
bijouterie peuvent aller de plusieurs
semaines à plusieurs années peut
pratiquer en france le travail du
filigrane d'argent est un art très
ancien mais peut enseigner
frédéric a dû suivre quelques jours de
cours en suisse
c'est ce savoir-faire qui caractérise
ses bijoux j'aime le côté unique de la
création en fait je reproduis très très
rarement un bijou et quand on me demande
voilà deux temps
un client qui qui flashent notamment sur
cette marque je lui ai refait une bague
dans l'esprit mais jamais complètement
la même c'est très important c'est un
peu ma signature en fait en parallèle de
la création frédéric dispense des stages
pour transmettre sa passion et se dit
aujourd'hui épanoui dans son travail
le papillon est prêt à s'envoler il est
temps à présent de passer à notre
entretien du jour ce soir nous allons
parler d'un problème de société celui du
vieillissement de la population et de
l'importance des auxiliaires de vie
auprès des personnes âgées pour nous en
parler ce soir véronique chatel bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste et auteur
du livre
reportage sur les auxiliaires de vie à
domicile intitulé je veux vieillir chez
moi et publié aux éditions ce créneau
dans la collection les carnets de
l'information de l'info pardon donc ce
livre est fait de portraits l'interview
de témoignages et de spécialistes du
grand âge
voilà vous avez comment allez-vous vous
le montrer à travers ce livre j'ai eu
envie qu'on incarne enfin d'incarner ce
que signifiait l'expression vieillir
chez soi il ya beaucoup de personnes par
opposition enfin beaucoup de personnes
âgées notamment qui par opposition au
projet de peut-être un jour vieillir
dans une maison de retraite 10 à moi je
tout cas moi j'espère que je vais venir
chez moi et donc c'est un projet aussi
des pouvoirs publics vieillir chez soi
coûterait moins cher coûte pour
l'instant mais bon moins cher que
vieillir dans une dans une dans un ehpad
et voilà on se contente de ça va venir
chez soi c'est un programme qui se
limite à cette expression et j'ai envie
de de savoir ce que ça recouvrait qu'est
ce que c'est donc que vieillir chez soi
et surtout qu'est ce que ça suppose
à quoi faut-il se prépare et si un jour
on veut vraiment dire chez soi et c'est
là qu'on rencontre des travailleurs
invisibles ces auxiliaires de vie
s'enquit vieillir chez soi n'est pas
possible à partir d'un certain temps ça
veut pas dire que tous les gens âgés
seront un jour en perte d'autonomie mais
il ya de fortes chances si on vieillit
si on vit longtemps et qu'on a la chance
de vieillir aussi longtemps qu on ait un
jour besoin d'avoir des professionnels
du domicile
alors c'est un vrai un reportage
beaucoup de photos dans ce livre vous
avez mis 3 ans dans cette enquête afin
de publier le livre comment ça c'est un
petit peu déroulé quand vous avez pris
vos contacts j'ai travaillé
effectivement avec le photographe serge
verglas est donc bon trois ans alors pas
en continu voilà mes trois ans
effectivement c'était long gestionnaire
notamment les yvelines plusieurs
territoires territoire rural territoires
urbains semi urbain de banlieue et c'est
pour voir des situations différentes
ce n'est pas une manière de vieillir
chez soi il ya autant de manières qu'il
y a de jean profil de deux modes de vie
d'habitat d'urbanisme enfin c'est ça qui
est intéressant
donc je j'ai travaillé avec des
associations ou des structures privées
de services à domicile qui m'ont mis en
contact avec des professionnels qui
voulaient bien montrer ce qu'elle
faisait
puis je suis entré au domicile de
personnes âgées qui aussi ont accepté de
de se livrer comme ça dans dans ce dans
ce mois peau mois bo qui représente le
domicile et parce que enfin j'ai été
très content en tout cas de 2
de découvrir la complicité de ces
professionnels du domicile qui se sont
prêtés à montrer ce qu'elle faisait et
qui ont assez vite compris que dans
l'observation d'une prise en charge
d'une aide aide au ménage aide à la
toilette et c'est ce que je cherchais à
comprendre c'était l'engagement qu'elle
mettait ou de la de jeu pousse le balej
je nettoie un évier
il y à il ya tout un regard une
adaptation au lieu de vie un engagement
de sa personne dans ce qu'elle découvre
à un moment j parce que chaque jour est
un jour différent fin voilà donc seysses
c'est pour ça que ça a été long il a
fallu tisser aussi des des liens de
confiance et gagner c'est confiance
c'est vrai que quand on pense à vire
chez soi donc voilà à domicile on pense
également à la solitude ce que vous avez
voulu montrer justement c'est qu'avec
ces auxiliaires de vie
finalement la solitude est un petit peu
comblé oui c'est vrai que beaucoup de
structures du domicile souhaite vendre
du service et non des professionnels
humain c on est dans un monde où la cie
leur économie aussi prétend que l'on
pourrait vieillir sans avoir recours à
de l'humain on y suffirait d'être
connecté pour pouvoir pallier à toutes
et toutes sortes de défaillance etc
or j'ai rencontré des tas de
professionnels du domicile qui disent
être accueilli comme le soleil d'être en
tout cas d'être d'être nommé mont-soleil
ma bonne fée etc et qui sont se trouve
très valorisé dans leur travail par le
sentiment de d'allumer la petite
étincelle dans l'oeil de réenclencher
comme ça la flamme de la chaudière de
tous et de toutes ces personnes qui sont
pas forcément souvent faim qui sont pas
forcément dans la solitude mais qui sont
en tout cas dans une forme d'isolement
social pour beaucoup parce que parce que
voilà plus on vieillit plus plus se
déplacer se mouvoir et compliqué à
prendre les transports et cédera donc
effectivement souvent ces professionnels
sont des sentinelles comme ça et 2
de la vie et font sont des passerelles
entre ces domicile est un peu un peu
watts et on peut retrancher et la ville
à vis de l'extérieur qui bat son plein
c'est aussi difficile qu'on pense à
vieillir chez soi parce qu'il ya
notamment une question financière une
fois que l'aviation préoccupations
financières que les familles pensent
parfois ne pas pouvoir forcément assumer
oui c'est sûr que bon avoir recours aux
eaux talent au savoir-faire au
professionnalisme de ces de ces
travailleurs du domicile
bon un pic est en tout cas si on
souhaite être si on souhaite toucher une
allocation de perte d'autonomie
l'apa il faut montrer et faire preuve de
besoin particulier donc effectivement il
ya tout un processus administratif qui
est bien normal il faut que ces les
besoins qui ne peuvent plus être
effectués par les personnes elles-mêmes
soient évalués et c'est donc donc le bon
alors tous les gens qui ont montré pas
dedans je ne certaine manière touche
touche une aide qui va pas forcément
payer l'intégralité de des personnes qui
vont venir au domicile et qui bon va va
en tout cas les soutenir mais ce que je
constate c'est que les on est encore
dans une société où les gens du mal à
demander de l'aide et ont du mal à
envisager que demander de l'aide c'est
pas et ça n'est pas honteux il n'ya pas
il n'ya pas se sentir coupable et que
finalement demander de l'aide ou ne pas
en demander ça n'est pas qu'une question
financière c'est ça l'est mais pas que
et c'est aussi des choix à faire un
certain moment je pense qu'on peut se
dire quand on anticipe son
vieillissement enfin si on si on on
pense qu'on vivra longtemps aussi se
dire qu'à un moment donné on aura besoin
d'une aide et que ce sera peut-être plus
confortable plutôt qu'avoir de devoir se
contenter peut-être que de deux heures
par jour ou par semaine d'une auxiliaire
de vie se dire donc on financera soi
même une troisième heure pour deux pour
un temps de lecture de balades etc
ça fait partie finalement on a cette
chance de vieillir longtemps parce qu'on
vit longtemps de plus en plus donc
essayons aussi nous donner des moyens de
de financer donc c'est en fait la
question d'aidé financé à la fois elle
questionne la société dans son ensemble
les institutions les pouvoirs publics
mais le questionne aussi les individus
est d'autant plus qu'on peut pas
demander ou z ans comme la famille de
pallier à tous c'est insupportable sinon
c'est donc un problème société je le
rappelle vous êtes évinoise ce que vous
venez de vous n'etes elancourt vous avez
également des interviews des acteurs
locaux et politique dans ce livre on
apprend notamment que l'urbanisme c'est
un aussi des facteurs parfois qu'il peut
être compliqué pour voir rester chez soi
et vivre voilà longtemps dans son propre
domicile
ah oui complètement et c'est vrai que le
bassin de saint quentin en yvelines qui
est ponctué de petites résidences
pavillonnaires ou les gens ont été très
contents de vivre comme ça la bri est
loin est loin du bruit etc
on peut se retrouver tourner un peu con
tre et ressemble enfin elle finit par
ressembler une forme de tombeau j'ai
rencontré des gens des gens très âgés
qui vous vont bien sauf qu'ils ne
peuvent pas utiliser leur voiture sauf
que le effectivement il ya plus de bons
n'y a pas de banc public pour aller de
chez soi au supermarché par exemple la
supérette était pouvoir s'asseoir faire
des pauses enfin bref
donc effectivement c'est très important
dans le vieillir chez soi enfin sur tout
cas si les pouvoirs publics souhaitent
que les gens choisissent cette prennent
cette option pour leurs vieux jours de
d'adapter l'urbanisme et de et de
facilité et enfin ça n'est pas qu'une
question personnelle vieillir chez soi
ça c'est vraiment une question de
politique beaucoup plus globale est ce
que vous pensez que actuellement le
gouvernement la politique française
prend suffisamment en compte justement
cette problématique depuis le début 2016
cette fameuse loi d'adaptation de la
société au vieillissement qui justement
intègrent cette idée de l'adaptation
d'urbanisme architecture de 2 et qui
souhaite enfin j'ai j'ai entendu
plusieurs élus qui pensent que le
vieillissement ne relève pas que du
ministère des personnes âgées ça devrait
relever de tous les ministères de la
culture de l'énergie de dd des grands
ensembles de la ville enfin bref
et donc je pense que bon il ya un
changement de culture qui s'opèrent
doucement et sûrement notamment grâce à
tous les baby boomers qui arrivent et
qui eux ont le bien l'intention de
vieillir chez eux mais ne veulent pas
accepteront sans doute pas d'être
complètement isolés et coupés du monde
alors c'est un très beau livre il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de photos beaucoup
d'illustrations et si on voit vraiment
des vrais des vraies histoires d'amitié
le lien intergénérationnel entre
justement les aidant les auxiliaires de
vie aussi les personnes qui ont essayé
de rester à vivre à leur domicile je le
rappelle je veux vieillir chez moi de
véronique chatel est publié aux éditions
screen est haut dans la collection et
karine info merci beaucoup d'être venu
sur notre plateau sinon avoir répondu à
nos questions
tout autre sujet à présent du 7 au 8
mars 2016 la ville de paris organisé en
partenariat avec l'union européenne son
premier exercice zonage de gestion de
crise baptisée uc cannes à un exercice
qui visait à simuler la gestion une crue
majeure de la scène en ile-de-france
dans ce cadre un exercice de
sécurisation et d'opérations de
dépollution a été organisée à limay dans
les yvelines un test grandeur nature qui
a mobilisé 87 partenaires franciliens
publics et privés regardez ce reportage
réalisé avec des images gracieusement
donnés par une première sortie de son
lit la scène a aujourd'hui atteint un
pic de crue de 8 mètres conséquences sur
la zone portuaire de limay un camion
avec nacelle s'est abattue sur des
camions citernes contenant des produits
chimiques ici du chlore et du gasoil
ce scénario catastrophe est en réalité
un exercice grandeur nature un exercice
de dépollution que la france va mener
conjointement avec l'union européenne
sur un exercice de ce type c'est de
s'entraîner avec nos collègues des
outils de sécurité civile français qui
possède d'énormes moyens capacité est de
travailler ensemble et s'entraîner dans
un même temps avec nos collègues
européens alors comparé le matériel
utilisé mettre en oeuvre et en pratique
le matériel des pompiers français des
pompiers européens et aussi bas il ya la
barrière de la langue qui fait qu' un
exercice de difficulté supplémentaire
qui doit nous obliger effectivement à
s'entendre pour mener au mieux
l'opération pour cette opération quatre
pays ont répondu à l'appel
l'italie l'espagne la république tchèque
et la belgique l'enjeu travailler
ensemble et rapidement pour éviter toute
contamination
ernest lui dirige l'équipe espagnole il
ya une équipe à la coupe de
l'intervention pour faire la
reconnaissance l'intervention et les à
notre petite équipe qui sent la coupe de
la décontamination le matériel et esther
ce sont les mêmes à peu près restaurer
un peu la procédure initiale le mode de
marasme et la percée d'or pour la
reconnaissance et où c'est pareil au
final l'opération est un succès une
coordination qui a prouvé l'efficacité
du plan d'action européen
la dernière grande crue de la seine date
de 1910 mais constitue aujourd'hui un
risque majeur que la région sera amenée
à connaître
il est temps à présent de passer notre
chronique pour ce soir nous accueillons
à mélanie potier bonsoir mélanie alors
ce mercredi dans la chronique il va être
question de mobilité durable puisque un
projet est en cours à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
le projet mobile r est actuellement en
test mais pourrait bientôt être mis en
place à grande échelle
oui pour que c est déjà lu vs qc six
unités de formation de recherche un
observatoire lové est ce qu une école
d'ingénieurs de zut et et autres
établissements soit 13 sites éparpillés
à saint quentin en yvelines versailles
et vélizy encore rambouillet ou
mantes-la-jolie et c'est ce qui
intéressait la région qui est à
l'origine du projet pour
développée donc des solutions de
mobilité durable l'un des premiers
éléments développés c'est l'auto partage
qui peut être associé à du covoiturage
écoutez remet en course il est chef du
projet chez du wild est donc nombre de
mobiles ce faire on trouve vraiment
c'est l'association covoiturage plus
auto partage qui est le plus pertinent
parce que ça permet déjà aux locataires
de diviser les frais d'un d'une location
de voiture à turin autopartage et c'est
quand même plus fins et assez facile
pour un étudiant de trouver quelqu'un
qui est dans la même classe ou que qui
mange tout le toujours à continuer avec
lui comme compagnons de route français
mélanie les campus universitaires
universitaire pardon sont de plus en
plus grands l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines
ces vingt mille étudiants ça fait du
monde comment trouver un covoitureur ou
une voiture à louer alors pour le moment
mobis faire est encore à l'état de
projet ils font donc passer par le site
de la société dit woods
un formulaire est à remplir sur une page
dédiée à l'université les étudiants
intéressés indique le campus où le quai
auquel il est rattaché et le
propriétaire qui souhaite mettre à
disposition son véhicule décide du
montant de location
la société prend une commission de 20 %
est ce que tous les campus on être
concernés alors vont être sûr on est
dans le dans le projet par contre pour
le moment c'est le campus de l'ufr des
sciences basé à versailles qui est le
site pilote des professeurs et étudiants
travaillent sur le projet
tous ces acteurs se rencontrent une à
deux fois par mois pour des réunions de
copilotage pour le moment on a parlé des
déplacements en voiture mais il ya aussi
les modes de circulation douce on le
voit à l'écran et l'ufr des sciences a
mis à disposition depuis 2014 sans vélo
l'emprunt est gratuit c'est sur une
journée une charte est signée par
l'étudiant le professionnel il se voit
remettre une clé à l'accueil de l'ue frc
versailles grand parc donc qui nous a
subventionné pour que nous puissions
faire aboutir un projet qui nous tenait
à coeur à savoir donc l'achat de vélos
afin que le personnel de l'ufr et ses
étudiants puissent aller sans problème
vers le centre ville
investir le centre ville et donc
rapproché le but c'était de rapprocher
l'ufr des sciences de la ville de
versailles
alors il est aussi question du
développement d'une plateforme une
plateforme qui permettra de trouver un
covoitureur de louer une voiture de
mettre en location sa propre voiture
mais aussi d'échangés entre les
étudiants parce que si l'objet de movie
ce faire c'est avant tout développer la
mobilité durable c'est aussi de créer du
lien entre tous ces acteurs ils sont
très nombreux sur les sur les campus
il se croise tous les jours et parfois
ne se connaissent pas les étudiants les
enseignants les personnels
administratifs écouter à nouveau romain
course et aujourd'hui on lit beaucoup
mais facebook c'est déjà ça en fait non
facebook est un outil merveilleux mais
pour ça c'est pas pertinent parce que si
on appâte 20 tous les étudiants ont pas
tous les autres étudiants de l'ueh ce qu
en contact ou en ami donc si ils veulent
faire un cours et tu rajoutes faire la
promotion d'une soirée ou ne serait-ce
que vendre un livre de l'année dernière
à on va dire à ceux qui arrivent
facebook ne permet pas et notre site va
le permettre
il ya aussi une initiative assez
étonnante puisque des étudiants
travaillent sur une cartographie des
bâtiments de l'ufr des sciences
le campus est grand et se découpe en
plusieurs bâtiments
cette cartographie a permis de
développer un outil pour se déplacer sur
le campus voire carrément dans les
bâtiments et biens des frais d'avoir des
voitures voilà ils pourront déjà se
déplacer à pied avec un petit gps
cartographier tout autre sujet à présent
loisirs c'était ce week-end les
passionnés de timbres se sont réunis
l'association philatélique de maurepas
organisait son exposition annuelle
l'occasion de présenter leur passion et
de montrer qu'elle n'est pas aussi
vintage eux qu'on le croit patrick keil
jacques de dixmude pour ces images ils
font la fierté de leurs collectionneurs
tout s'éteindre appartiennent aux
cinquante adhérents de l'association
philatélique de maurepas chaque année
ils se réunissent pour exposer le fruit
de leur passion d'antan sensations c'est
un événement très important parce que ça
permet d'une part à chacun de s'exprimer
de faire voir son travail et d'autre
part ça permet de faire en sorte que les
mots repas siens puis se voir ce qui
serait dans l'association et pour plaire
aux morte azir l'association un secret
fait réaliser chaque année d'étendre à
l'éffigie de la ville au niveau havre
d'art il ya pas mal de choses sur mort
pas là cette année on a pris des des
fresques qui était fait par le passé
donc de re découvrir ça ça nous permet
nous de rechercher des choses
intéressantes
et puis les les habitants de maurepas
bain quelquefois ils nous disent ou es
ce que vous avez trouvé cette fresque ou
es ce que vous avez trouvé ça et c'est
intéressant
la vente de s'éteindre permet de
financer l'association mais aussi
parfois d'attirer de nouveaux
collectionneurs d
il y avait plusieurs teintes sur mort
pas ça je savais pas que peut faire
autant contre caen
autant de choses avec mais avec juste
détendre en fait et les nouvelles
recrues sont toujours les bienvenus à
l'heure du mail le timbre résiste encore
et l'association à philatélique de
maurepas est toujours à la recherche de
nouveaux adhérents voilà si ça vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à les contacter
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis rester
avec nous à suivre l'émission kiosque
présenté par sephora namani votre
émission culturelle sur saint quentin en
yvelines
quant à moi je vous retrouve demain pour
une nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée